Steve good morning how are you good
morning how are you I'm doing okay how
do you feel oh well I feel better than
some of the guys you got working for you
I hear you uh yeah well you guys uh got
a hernia yeah well um double hernia
doubled yeah toast is since you're doing
sports talk radio is it a sports hernia
or non-sports burning well he doesn't do
sports so it's kind of hard to get a
sports hernia I mean you know stranger
things have happened yeah he's not an
athlete though right yeah that's true
but I mean you know you know they say
the moon sighs on the dogs why how long
would you be out with a sports hernia um
all season or in season in season in
season man one of those is hard to play
with um but generally five two to three
weeks you know um all season you know
they probably let you try to let it heal
fully so six to eight what's the young
he's not it he's not an athlete so he's
probably you know he may be out for you
know you may be unable to function for
probably four months what's the worst
injury you played through during a
season Oh splitting the web of my finger
okay and playing while receiver that's
kind of tough they sewed it up and then
you just had it bandaged yes and what
did Flacco threw throw it too hard
actually it was James I call him James
but Jimmy Clausen Jimmy Clausen rough
Jiali it was actually just us it just
hit at the right spot it split and taped
it up and put a little pat on there and
was head out a day and a half today and
I was back at it who's the guy that when
when you're across from him you know
that it's just going to be physical the
entire game it's going to be too
you were just yeah actually you know it
varies you know I'm in my age actually
in my age I get a lot of these young
young guys who you know tell me how old
I am they obviously defense coordinator
has told them what kind of player I am
so they tell me I'm not sure a lot of
difference coordinator that's a you know
I don't know what all of who blogs about
you know you're not that girl you're old
all that stuff um a lot of older players
like when me and Patrick or even like
Maxwell last you know like yesterday
some of these guys we go against each
other they understand look on run plays
it can be extra curriculum or you know
we can be kosher you know we can play
night and for the most part most guys
man they just want they want to get
block you know and they want to keep it
cool cuz they don't want to be you know
being shown getting smushed on
television when did you when's the last
time you had extracurricular um what
what year this season have you had
extracurricular with the defensive any
one know just the thing is uh I'll just
I just blocked the guys you know I go in
there cuz there's an expectation I got a
block on you know the Y receivers have
to make the running game go there's
times where they have nosey safeties so
if you get a nosey safety I got to come
down there and crack the safety um I had
a guy one time come down um first two
plays you ran it and I had to go hit the
safety and he said I'll be here all day
we went three straight plays well I had
to crack to safety by the fourth time he
was looking at me never lets me know
he's not gonna be here all day because
he that's not what he's expecting so
it's always good whenever I feel like
when I'm playing the defender if I make
him think that means he stops his feet
she starts to seat i means i'm a step
two steps ahead of him which puts them
at a disadvantage you've been in the
league 15 years the difference in how
you were hit first two or three years as
opposed to how guys tackled now is
[Music]
that's interesting because I've been hit
you know I've been hit hard a number of
years but i think when i first came to
lead i remember we're playing against
some oldest Smith hit me here's the
cornerback for the New England Patriots
we were running a play called sperm
right officer um Chris Winky was there
was a quarterback we ran a sprint right
uh Chris Winky threw the ball the next
thing I remember I was looking up at the
sky so I I think the difference that
I've learned um the guys are I don't
believe that players are stronger and
faster you know I hear people say that
but will you go back and think about it
you don't see a lot of Jevon Kearse was
a free do you see a lot of developers
out there six foot seven the way he was
the way you can jump and run mm-hmm you
know those they're not bigger than Jevon
Kearse they have hybrid linebackers um
they have mold you know more mobile
quarterbacks but they're not bigger
faster maybe a guy that was on curse
type is playing quarterback vs dean you
know he's you know 260 pounds you know
playing quarterback versus a guy playing
the end I can jump off the jump out
there Jim I think that's the difference
he Steve Smith the ravens wide receiver
when whenever your name is brought up
during a game your age it feels like is
always brought up yeah like I mean I
understand it they don't they don't say
um you know they don't talk about other
players say oh 24 years old well they
might do that with Odell Beckham to
remind you how young he is but it feels
like okay whenever your name is
mentioned it's 37 year old Steve Smith
yeah are you proud of it or does it
bother you I guess it depends in which
way is a dress you know and brought up
know if you're saying that
you can't depend on a 37 year old why
receiver to help to you know rely on him
to play my question is why not why can't
you depend on a 37 year old when the
same way you could depend on the 27 year
old you mean what's the difference you
have the Patriots next Monday night have
you asked would you ask brady for a
jersey or have you ever done that after
a game oh I I really don't another big
fan of the jersey exchange I know in
Europe and unless your soccer fan they
do it and then you know the young guys
are doing it but um I've had guys
sometimes ask me for my jersey on teams
that nice in a nice way I'm not
necessarily sure I want your Jersey so I
try to do yes we do you know with it
with these years that are coming up I
just don't really want to give out my
judgment because you know I'm gonna have
grandkids Moses is 19 you know I got my
boys they still look up to dad so I you
know I want to keep some of that stuff
for them as well well what would it
Brady after monday night said uh hey
Steve you want to exchange jerseys um I
doubted he would do that but what a Tom
Brady a drew brees you know some of
those guys of course but if you talking
about a guy who's a gunner on special
teams and creamed honey jerseys with you
you know I'm just gonna be honest and
some people may hear this goal he's a
jerk I mean hey you know your nitrate if
you're working in a big company and has
a male role you have a good parking spot
you're not gonna trade partner spots
with a guy in the mailroom just to be
nice and he's all the way on the other
side of of the campus right Oh work yeah
yeah well yeah I'm straight but I
appreciate you I deliver my mail to my
box but overly watch us [ __ ] you know
have you ever done stand-up comedy no I
don't my wife says I'm funny things I
said because I said
elsevier which I'm not trying to be fun
though you could get on it these
comedians who cut my Chris Rock comes on
stage and he just kind of you know
pouncing he's ready to pounce on
everybody just put on the prowl when
he's out there you could do that get on
stage just start firing away man get
somebody get counterpart to help you
Kevin Hart to help you right 15 minutes
of stand-up you could do it every good
that'd be awesome does not I'm not that
comfortable with it no I think you'd do
fine hey come be careful he's the
37-year old Steve Smith and I mean that
in a good way he soaked over over a
thousand cake you haven't decided about
next year right uh yeah beside it you're
coming back yeah yeah no no you're done
well I'm what I'm trying to do is enjoy
well I'll see them during the highlights
next season Steve thank you bud have a
good week three save all right met Steve
Smith ravens wide receiver the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience
[Music]